dw correspondent in kiev mcconnelly
spoke earlier by phone to a resident of
gerson which is also under russian
control
this city is in southern ukraine near
the black sea coast it was seized by
russian troops in early march a week ago
russian soldiers fired on civilians who
were protesting peacefully there against
their occupiers
the 30-year-old ukrainian man who were
calling james to protect his identity
gave us his insight into everyday life
in jerusalem since the russian takeover
i've heard the explosion and
then a couple of minutes later
my friend called me up and
he told me the war is on
nothing's been delivered
neither food nor medicine so what you do
is
you you walk or you take a bicycle
for a trip in search of
money
food
and medicine
most of the coffee shops
sell now
potatoes and
cabbage instead of marshmallows and
cakes
[Applause]
at first it was
quite overwhelming and
the ukrainians expressed all the
emotions that
they felt about the invasion
by
looking into the eyes of the russian
soldiers
they kept on doing this every day for
the first
three weeks
probably you've seen on some point that
the ukrainians started uh pushing back
to
russian uh lorries
and um
on the same day
we've received a report from russia
that
some of the generals
ordered the police forces and hassan to
suppress the demonstrations he i think
i think the
ukrainian demonstration movement
crossed some lines and
it made some russian officials very
angry
we hear the explosions become
hotter and louder
and yesterday night i've seen my
hanging door vibrate
like i've never seen it
vibrate before
the ukrainians are getting closer to
town we want our army to liberate us but
we don't know what happens afterwards
and we are very much afraid of
what is happening to the city if the
ukrainian army liberates us and the
russians
remain on the left bank of nepal and
[Music]
if they start shelling at the city no
one really knows but until now they've
been shedding every city they could if
it's not in their
hands
the red cross has launched a new attempt
to get civilians out of the devastated
city of mariupol in southern ukraine the
port city has been under siege by
russian forces for weeks tens of
thousands of people are believed to be
trapped in desperate circumstances and
exposed to constant bombardment
ukrainian president vladimir zelinsky
said on friday that some people did
manage to escape against the odds
arriving to relative safety
after weeks of shelling
over 3 000 were able to escape mariopol
on friday
but it's a journey full of risks
one woman recounts her fears as she
crossed a russian checkpoint
it was very difficult she said
i was afraid they would take my son away
they made him throw his phone on the
ground and trample on it because he had
american music
an attempt by the red cross to deliver
aid and evacuate civilians
ended in failure
the organization said the lives of
thousands
depended on evacuations
uh we haven't heard anything from our
people uh in mariopol for more than one
week
there is there is still our staff
working in marijuana plus we have there
are still around six uh volunteers
working in maribel but we do not know uh
anything about their destiny if they are
live
we know that they have difficulties
because they do not have um well they
have problems with transport uh red
cross cars were partially damaged our
office was partially damaged so that's
the situation
unable to wait
others fled the bombs in cars
the white cloth a sign they mean no harm
as many as a hundred and seventy
thousand are still trapped in this city
that's been devastated by war
this former orphanage
now a makeshift bomb shelter
for those who can't escape
we came here to the basement she said
we stay here because we don't know what
happened to our apartment
we ran here with what we had
the red cross said they will attempt
once again to reach the city on saturday
in a bid to rescue the innocent
from what is left of mariopol
for the latest we can speak to our
correspondent rebecca ritters who is in
the western ukrainian city of levive
rebecca good to see you
so according to ukrainian authorities
humanitarian corridors are now in place
to evacuate people from mariupol but
what are you hearing about the today's
rescue attempts how how are they going
it's so difficult to get accurate and
up-to-date information on the
evacuations and the situation
in that city of mariupol where it's
really difficult yesterday we were sort
of getting conflicting information uh we
know that the red cross has been trying
to get into that city as you were saying
in the report there that red cross has
been trying to get into mario paul to
bring in much needed aid but to also
bring out the thousands of civilians
that are still trapped in there um we
know that those attempts so far have
failed but as you've just reported on
thursday we know that a couple of
thousands of people were able to get out
that's in a sort of a private convoy
basically people just taking a chance
taking their own private vehicles and
risking it to get out of the dire
situation of mario paul that's happening
in mario paul right now and again
yesterday another two to three thousand
also managed to evacuate we got
confirmation of that from mario paul's
city council but the red cross once
again turned around they weren't able to
get in and today i'm still i have no
confirmation on numbers or whether or
not any of those
attempts were failed or people were able
to get out but i can tell you that today
in la viv in the western part of ukraine
relatively safe compared to the rest of
the country as you can see people behind
me here out on the street out and about
the 300 or so of people from mariupol
arrived in this city so there are some
people getting out but many many more up
to a hundred and sixty thousand people
we're hearing are still trapped inside
that city of mariupol
now rebecca we're also hearing reports
about explosions in the city of venera
which we understand is near a nuclear
plant
what more can you tell us about that
that's right
well it was a series of explosions
it was confirmed by the country by
ukraine's nuclear energy agency as you
say it's near the nuclear plant of
zaparisia in in zaparisia also
significantly the town where a lot of
the people from mario poland from those
eastern
cities are actually evacuating to but uh
more concerning perhaps
is that it there it is home to the fifth
largest i believe power plant in europe
uh and it's uh sorry one of the biggest
in fact but it um gives
ukraine about a fifth of ukraine's
energy so it's a really huge plant and
of course everyone it has fears uh
bringing up memories of chernobyl 1986
that huge nuclear explosion that
happened here and nobody wants to see
anything like that that the area where
the plant is has been under russian
control since march 4th
and everyone's just uh waiting to see
what's going to happen there and very
concerned about what will happen with
the power
plant that was dw correspondent rebecca
ritters reporting from uh for us from
the city of la vie thank you so much
let's get you up to speed on some of the
other global headlines
video footage just released has revealed
to the destruction many towns of many
towns in north eastern ukraine suffered
during russia's invasion the ukrainian
state tv footage shows the town of sumi
near the russian border which has been
under siege ukrainian forces have
retaking areas in the north of the
country as russian troops withdraw
ukrainian documentary filmmaker and
photographer maxim levine has been found
dead in a village near the capital kiev
he'd been missing since mid-march
according to initial information levin
was shot by russian soldiers however
investigations are still ongoing
sri lanka has imposed a nationwide
curfew to stop protests against the
government the new restrictions will be
in place till monday morning earlier
this week demonstrators clashed with
police during protests over shortages of
basic supplies like food fuel and
medicine
hong kong authorities are asking the
entire population that's 7.4 million
people to self-test for covet next week
chief executive kerry lahm said a
compulsory universal test was essential
as the territory struggles to contain a
fifth wave of infectious operation
sergey lotznitsa is one of ukraine's
best known and most controversial film
directors for years with his features
and documentaries he has been warning
that russia was planning a war against
his country now his fiction has become
ukraine's reality
[Music]
civilians running from bombing in
ukraine
this isn't yesterday's news but a film
from 2018 set in donbass eastern ukraine
where russian forces are supporting
pro-putin separatists
the civilians are actors staging a fake
news massacre for russian tv
propaganda to justify the military
incursion
ukraine director sergey los niza shows
how for years russia planned its war of
aggression against ukraine but the west
wasn't paying attention
western liberal democracies were asleep
when the new russia was forming when it
was attacking in grozny chechnya again
when it was attacking georgia crimea
donbass and ukraine and so on
what we're witnessing now is in a way
the consequences of this sleep of this
lack of counteraction on the part of the
west
in his 2014 documentary maidan on a
pro-west uprising las nica used only
long takes to capture what he says was
the truth of the historic moment
even the style of my film is in a way
opposed to this method of propaganda
like the russian propaganda newsreels
which presented a very different picture
of what was happening in ukraine
but los niza is also controversial in
ukraine
in part because his documentary baba yar
context about a nazi massacre outside
kiev in 1941
included scenes showing locals
celebrating the arrival of the nazis
and standing by as they round up the
jews
but also because even after the russian
invasion los niza refuses to support a
full boycott of russian cinema
in response the ukrainian film academy
kicked him out
i'm absolutely against the proposed
total boycott of russian cultural
figures and russian filmmakers who've
actually been opposing the regime and
have been condemning the war because if
we do that if we boycott them as well as
everyone else in a way we'll be
betraying them
says he's no prophet and he's no
politician his films don't speak for
ukraine
but try to depict the world and the war
as he sees it
you